[Applause]
today's video is sponsored by
surf shark paul shone is a 23 year old
fight promoter from san diego california
he was asked over 50 questions by a
polygraph examiner
21 have been chosen for tonight hi my
name is maria and i'm paul's girlfriend
hi i'm karen and i'm paul's mom i'm the
sister jackie
i'm enrique and i'm paul's dad have you
ever lied to a woman about the fact that
you live with your mother
okay this one is easy this one's cute
there'll be more this is the first one
it's gonna turn from
real quick i once i lied but i didn't
volunteer the information
it depends how it played out like if the
person never asking never goes on topic
you didn't lie but if a person is like
so where do you live you know uh what a
roommate and the roommate is your mom
come on now come on
that's a lie that's a blatant lie
yeah you know with my roommate
you live with your mom no my mom lives
with me
you know that's
alive man yes
have you ever had sex with someone and
kept her underwear as a trophy
you guys looking at his face leave a
comment below if you think he's he's the
kind of guy who does this kind of stuff
dude what leave a comment if you think
that the sky is blue same same
[Music]
yes that
answer is i have a whole trophy case
you you didn't have
oh wow
bro you did not have
to confirm like a dawn king perm that
you had a whole trophy case
oh hell no
this
true
[Music]
like his buddy went oh
vegan
the way he said that he knows are there
things in your sexual history
that you keep secret from maria maria
what do you think the answer to this
one's gonna be
i don't don't know yes
it's a man-in-law man
hey hey no
don't you put us in with you
you you decide to go on a show you go on
a show
on your own you don't bring all the man
into this
uh we don't know you we didn't nothing
to you don't don't
don't bring all the men in no man maria
he'd love to tell you but
he's evoked the man law any questions
you want to ask him
we'll talk about it later she seems
disillusioned
yes she seems like she's not capable of
seeing people
but she's shocked by these things it's
like how do i don't know this dude
and i'm not surprised and you know like
you ever relate a whole
a whole ass relationship with a man and
you get you surprised
i feel like that's some stuff you you
should know and if you don't then you
have to ask yourself why am i not seeing
this person for who they are
when everyone else can see them do you
think you would like to have
children with maria someday
this is like for what 20 grand this man
was about to break up with this girl
because
god i think that's what it is it's
people that are on the bridge
on the brink of breaking up and they're
like you know what
might as well yeah might as well make a
little book on the side
no maria does that hurt your feelings
[Applause]
she's a beautiful girl and anybody would
want to have kids
you probably heard she's a beautiful
girl and anybody
could want to have wanna have kids with
her that's what you heard
what i heard is to the streets like
y'all can have her i'm i'm good if he
says that
everybody can have kids with her and you
don't break up with him
right after the show wow
well wonderful news for you guys because
i do have updates about them
and what happened to them after the show
let's carry on
because preach there's more oh
[Music]
do you keep a spreadsheet of all the
women that you have had sexual relations
with why wouldn't you do that
hold up hold up actually we don't know
if he actually did let's watch
oh my god
wow
what's your answer i like to be
organized
so yes i do
where were we why would you do that
ah jesus like why would you
do such a dumb why would you do
that wow
oh wow if
you didn't know
what a douchebag was
he keeps a spreadsheet it's just a
spreadsheet
all about the sheets he spreads all the
cheeks he spread
it's a spreadsheet
oh man he definitely excels at that
yo today's video is sponsored by surf
shark vpn
so vpn is basically an application or a
web extension that you could use on your
web browser or on your internet
to mask your ip address basically hiding
your location
from whatever website you're interacting
with now you might think
why would i want to hide where i'm at it
doesn't matter well unfortunately there
are places that block you
based off of your ip address and so if
you're trying to view
online content the online download
certain things based off where you live
those things could be restricted now i
like watching tv shows
feel me sometimes they're foreign feel
me and
when that happens basically i use a vpn
to be able to bypass that so i can watch
what i want to watch because i feel like
the internet's at its best
when everything's accessible if you use
promo code abba and preach
you get 83 off plus three months free
so take advantage of the deal watch what
you want to watch and don't be
restricted by anyone's barriers
you deserve to go wherever you'd like to
go
except if you want to physically fly
then buy yourself a plane ticket
[Music]
maria are you aware of the spreadsheet
no
that is not a giant red flag that is
china
because they have a red flag never we're
never going to china
we get invited to shanghai yeah we're
never going hey
oh no
you guys should come to chiang hai we do
comedy i'm like [ __ ] i think it's a
trap that's what you know it's funny
it was a [ __ ] who invited us i'm like
damn they got negros too for the cp
he tried to lure us my dude
[Music]
maria are you aware of the spreadsheet
no i was not aware
is she on the spreadsheet no comment i
know nothing
no comment you feel like you know
nothing yeah
is it simply a list or is there a name
category is there a rating
there's a rating oh
my god i'm guessing the next column has
a phone number
no no phone number i've never seen a man
dig himself
his own grave so much and like and smile
like an
idiot walking and enjoying it enjoying
the whole process
of oh my god what is this wait
i think we're the idiots okay
why this is like 2008 right yeah
this man just went on tv and advertised
himself to the world
probably is gonna break up with this
girl yeah and he's gonna make some money
out of the process
a bit yeah it's a genius
yeah especially for a guy that doesn't
care like that exactly there's a price
to pay let's get a price
yeah how many columns are there paul uh
five or six five or six columns have you
seen a federico yeah i've seen that it's
impressive actually
it's two guys that lack self-awareness
and that value the wrong things
maybe it's the household i was raised
like just the amount of shame i would
feel saying this in front of my parents
let alone like everybody else that they
know and how shame it's gonna bring to
them
the fact that you don't care maybe i'll
just just i guess i'm just raised in a
very different environment
this would be it would destroy
everything i know absolutely yeah my mom
was always
if you cannot honor me don't shame me
yeah you know what i mean no
yeah that's a good line why do you keep
the spreadsheet i'll actually blame it
on my sister
when i was 17 or 18 she gave me a little
black book
right you know every guy has a little
black sure and then
computer it was a computer age so i
threw a little black book and i
just put it in my spreadsheet i just
keep updating it's like she's realizing
all the red flags and that
the friend is not your ally
the family doesn't care was liking a lot
of things
how do you think is that you know what i
think it is what you need to do like
that because you want to be well
perceived
and now you're on national tv getting
embarrassed and you're not being well
perceived
in fact you look like a complete idiot
yup right because you know like
sometimes people just dating getting
relations people because they want
something around their arm that they can
show off
now imagine someone embarrassing you
like this in front of everybody because
he's big he got muscles and everything
yeah
yeah on the picture on a picture
remember this little black one
my little pimp book you gave me one of
it for a person
are you a dependable guy
sometimes depends on the situation but
yeah what do you guys think there's a
definition of not
dependable by definition like if you
if i'm building you a house you're like
is it is it sturdy is it dependable and
you're like
sometimes it depends you know it depends
on the situation it depends where you
stand
you know this house doesn't really sound
too sturdy itself
no it doesn't but thankfully it is what
it sounds or appears like is irrelevant
is it is it yeah you can look not
dependable what matters is are you
what do you want a house that looks
dependable or a house that is dependable
boom says i'm cracking floors
fix your floors no it's part of this
show it's about preaching the floor yeah
this floor reminds us to be humble
that's right i think you're very
dependable
maria you think so yeah
man betrayed your trust the whole show
you think he's dependable that's crazy
you've been through all this and they
ask your question and you still say yeah
girl there are blind men i can see
through
and that you didn't wow give this girl a
cane
question 13 do you think you could ever
be faithful to just one woman
[Music]
[Applause]
no
that answer is
[Applause]
that's 13 truthful answers you're doing
great
[Applause]
he's a good host you're doing great
buddy your social life
not so much but you
two more to a hundred thousand dollars
is this a surprise to you maria
yeah very disappointed
does that make you wonder how faithful
he's being to you as you guys are dating
right now
anything you want to add to this i
respect maria a lot
okay that's that's some trash you can't
bring a girl on the show
embarrass her like this and then say you
respect her
right yay yay uh anybody would love to
have a kid with her she's beautiful
do you want a kid nah this is like bro
there's a
imagine trying to get married to this
guy you saw me take her
as your wife ah anybody can take your
ass away
but do you nah
after you go now you have to go
with this dumb swap question 14
have you had relations with over 100
women
some people are looking at like hundreds
a lot you'd be surprised how many people
out here have done a hundred
very surprised it's actually super
common
especially in america man if you've been
to college
there's a lot of people who are cleaning
up spill on aisle five
somebody's there he's a janitor but he
looked damn good
are you doing it i'm telling you there's
somebody cleaning up everything on
college campuses
with with online dating and sexual
liberation and
women being like i want to live my best
life i'm going to party this weekend
it was easy then okay do the math do the
math
you go we pick up one girl every weekend
from when you're 18.
where that's 52 that's 52 women in one
one year
and one year now that's just one girl
there are three days on the weekend
and if you want you could also do that
we don't know that's just one
that's just one year multiply that by
multiple years
okay and then add in weekends and
weekdays for people who are really into
it and who got the options
travel a little bit if you've been doing
that for three years
it's not that crazy and you're like well
who would want it
yeah you'd be surprised a question
you're gonna have to answer
in front of your mother and your father
and your girlfriend
and your sister
yes
all right after this he takes the
hundred thousand and he leaves and uh
they eventually break up eventually
that's what apparently happens after
like trying to make it work and what's
not they broke up
every time i watch that show i'm just
like damn y'all really want that money
huh but it was
yeah it was really light it was and back
in the days you have to understand that
a hundred thousand dollars was a lot of
money
a lot of money i get that like you know
it's like if we're doing
it was it's exponential but yeah overall
i think
i understand why this show was
entertaining people liked it and also
know why i was taken off the air it was
really hard too there was a lot of
complaints it was not just people that
liked it it was
it was cringe oh man well we want to
hear your thoughts what do you guys
think about today's video
did you guys get surprised by anything
or repulsed if so by what you want to
get your comments in the
comments below crimson cringe
[Music]
foreign